toque tan significativo es el nacimiento
de este bebé y si implica que las
futuras generaciones podrían gozar de
una mayor protección contra este virus
buenos días raúl gracias por la
oportunidad este es un caso anecdótico
considerando que no se vacuna actual a
mujeres embarazadas en este caso este
era una trabajadora de la salud en
riesgo y por tanto recibió la vacuna y
como se ha visto con otras vacunas como
por ejemplo contra la tos ferina y
contra la influenza que son vacunas que
pueden ser administradas en las etapas
finales del embarazo y se ha podido
identificar anticuerpos transferidos de
la madre a estos niños así se ha podido
identificar anticuerpos de la vacuna de
que fueron anticuerpos generados en la
madre y transferidos a través de la
placenta a estos a estos niños
y por supuesto esto es lo que se conoce
como inmunización materna y de alguna u
otra forma hay un periodo de
vulnerabilidad de los niños donde
estos niños pueden ser susceptibles por
ejemplo a la tos ferina oa la influenza
y en este caso al alzar sus codos y esa
transferencia de anticuerpos podría
asegurar que estos niños tuvieran
protegidos al menos los primeros tres
meses de vida ahora vuelvo y repito este
ha sido un caso puntual y anecdótico y
esto necesita ser evaluado con más
detenimiento ahora doctor cree que este
caso sienta un precedente para
considerar la vacunación en el último
trimestre del embarazo de las mujeres
en este momento eso es poco probable
tome en cuenta que la agencia europea de
medicamentos y el comité de expertos de
la organización mundial de la salud y la
administración de alimentos y drogas de
los eeuu han sido muy enfáticos en que
no hay data dura no hay información
robusta que permite asegurar el perfil
de seguridad de las vacunas contra la
cob y en las mujeres embarazadas y de
hecho aquellas mujeres embarazadas que
reciben la vacuna son aquellas que
tienen algún riesgo de contagio como por
ejemplo estamentos de seguridad y
trabajadoras de la salud que sabemos que
están expuestas a la atención de
pacientes con lakovic y en esos casos
estas mujeres pues tienen una
conversación con sus costes atrás se
analizan los beneficios versus los
riesgos de la vacunación y son ellas las
que deciden vacunarse pero sin duda este
estudio es un llamado de atención para
hacer estudios más formales en este
grupo de la población que son las
mujeres embarazadas